DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello.
I'm Dustin Kirkland,
and I'm joined here
with Janet Kuo, software
engineer at Google,
and she's going to share with
us a bit of her experience
around Kubernetes
here at KubeCon
in Copenhagen. I understand that
working in the Workloads area
in Kubernetes, you've got some
expert perspectives on how
Kubernetes is changing
the life of an application
developer and an
IT administrator.
JANET KUO: So yes.
So Kubernetes
absolutely helps people
stop thinking about
infrastructure
or their computers,
machines, but start
thinking about the
things that they actually
care about like services and
how to run their applications
and also other
ecosystems such as Istio
also help people to decouple
the operations and developers
and make it very easy for
them to work independently
but coordinate together.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
So you'd say that it's really
helping application developers
spend time on their
application, their code,
far less so than the rest
of the infrastructure site.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
And the operations
team can work on things
like how to deploy
the applications
and how to manage them,
how to manage the policies
of those applications.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
So from a workload perspective,
what types of workloads
are you working to
improve in Kubernetes?
JANET KUO: So when
I first started,
Kubernetes only supported
stateless workloads then.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: So I wrote
the deployment API.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
JANET KUO: But then we
figured that people need
more than stateless workloads.
So then we have the
StatefulSet that
helps people to run their
Stateful applications.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Sure.
JANET KUO: And we also have
the jobs in CronJobs API
for batch processing.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: And most recently,
we had the native support
for Kubernetes in Spark.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
JANET KUO: And that's just
announced a while ago.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: And then if
people are using Spark,
they can run it on
Kubernetes Native now.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
Maybe for just giving
a bit of education
to some of the
people watching this,
can you maybe explain
some of the differences
between stateful, stateless,
and then batch processing,
and how that fits
in to Kubernetes?
JANET KUO: Sure.
So for stateless
applications, it's
things like your
web applications
that you may run multiple
instance of the same thing,
and they're seen as disposable.
So if something
dies, you don't care.
You just create more.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: Before
stateful applications,
you care about their
unique identity.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: So each of
your pod, your instance--
your application
instance-- will be similar,
but they'll each have their
own identity, their storage,
their network ID.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: Things like that.
And for batch
processing, it's for you
to be able to tell Kubernetes
how many pods I want to run
at a time to process my jobs.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
Yeah.
So maybe stateful applications
might be something
like a database, for instance?
JANET KUO: Yeah, a database
or a clustered application.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Cluster applications.
OK.
Stateless might be
something like a web front
end or a proxy.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right?
JANET KUO: Yes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And then batch
processing might be image--
JANET KUO: Yeah, image
processing or you
have a bunch of emails
you want to send
or you want to
back up something.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And do you
feel like all three of those
are equally as well supported
as Workloads in the Kubernetes
community today?
JANET KUO: So the stateless
applications are definitely
the most mature ones.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
Because that's where we started.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
That's where we started, and
that's the simplest model
that we support.
And for the other, like,
badge and stateful workflows,
they're still--
it's also pretty mature
because they're OGA.
But we keep hearing
people's feedback,
and we are trying
to improve those.
For example, for
batch, some people
want index job, like
they want better support.
And we may support
that in core or we
may create something, some
customized controllers
for people to be able
to do their own things
outside of core.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
And from a Workload
perspective, what do you
think are maybe some of the
most interesting CNCF and Cloud
Native ecosystem projects today?
JANET KUO: So there are
a bunch of projects.
For example, the
Istio is one of the--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Istio, yeah.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
CNCF project for me.
And also a lot of
people around Workloads,
they are building
different tools
for making it easy for you
to write your controllers.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: Like operators--
JANET KUO: --or like
Kubebuilder, things like that.
And that's very
interesting for me.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah,
that is really interesting.
So you're involved with the
community quite a bit, right?
Would you say most of
your work is done--
most of your engineering
work is done in the public,
in the Kubernetes
community at this point?
JANET KUO: Yeah.
So most of my work
lives on GitHub.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
And what's been your
experience so far
working in the
Kubernetes community?
JANET KUO: So the
community has grown a lot.
And at first, we were pushing
to find more and more people
to write code.
But now we find that we
have so many PRs to review,
and we are short on reviewers.
So we are trying to fix that by
ramping up more contributors,
make them own more
code, and be one
of the reviewers of
some expert areas.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
reviewing code still
takes a developer to do.
Are there other areas
of the community
that maybe non-developers can
get involved from a Kubernetes
perspective?
JANET KUO: Sure.
So for example, docs
is one of the most--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Appreciated.
JANET KUO: --appreciated
work, yeah.
So I remember when I joined,
where we don't have--
so people often
criticize, like, oh,
Kubernetes doesn't
have good docs,
or we cannot understand
the docs that you write.
So we've been improving
that, and we have created
more and more tutorials.
And we recently
did a doc revamp.
So if you go to the
Kubernetes style website,
you'll see the new format.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Kubernetes.o,
yeah, and documentation.
Yeah.
That's great.
Testing QA, of course.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right?
JANET KUO: Testing QA.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: I'm involved
in SIG product actually.
So there's a SIG PM, a
product management one.
So, yeah, there's
quite a few ways
to contribute to Kubernetes
outside of just writing
and reading code, right?
JANET KUO: Yeah.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Good.
Along those lines, do
you have any advice
for any students
or young engineers
who are coming to the
Kubernetes community
perhaps for the first time?
JANET KUO: So for
students, I would--
so we have one contributor
who is called Lucas.
He was a high school student
and was the youngest contributor
in our community.
So I want to call
out and to let people
know that don't feel intimidated
to join the Kubernetes
community.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: It's a
very welcoming community.
JANET KUO: Yeah,
it's very welcoming,
and if you don't
know where to start,
you can just start with browsing
all the SIGs and to figure out
which one you want to join.
And if you don't know
which one to join,
you can just join the
Contributor Experience,
because that's the first
you can get feedback,
like what I see from the
contributor side, what
process you can improve.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: It's great.
You called out Lucas.
Is there anyone else in
the Kubernetes community
that you find particularly
inspiring, someone
that you might want to
give a shout-out to,
a public thank you?
JANET KUO: Oh, there
are so many people.
For example, Brian Grant.
I first worked with him.
And then Eric [INAUDIBLE].
And for people
outside of Google,
I would say Clayton
is one of the earliest
contributors to Kubernetes.
And he's been involved in every
conversation and every PR,
and he has a lot of insights.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
one final question--
how did you first
come to Kubernetes?
What was your introduction
to Kubernetes like?
JANET KUO: So I came to--
so Kubernetes is my
first project at Google.
And when I
interviewed at Google,
I got a phone call
from Team Hawking,
and he just basically
sold me the idea.
Because Kubernetes wasn't
a thing at that time yet.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
JANET KUO: And a lot of
other orchestrating solutions
are much more popular
than Kubernetes,
and people even don't know
how to spell or pronounce
Kubernetes at that time.
So yeah.
After getting his phone
call, I was like, I'm in.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: I'm so.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
I'm sold.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Very cool.
Well, Janet, thank you
very much for your time.
JANET KUO: Yeah.
Thank you.